- Hey, everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
And this is another episode
of Overrated/Underrated
with me, Gary Vee.
(jazzy music)
♪ Overrated or underrated ♪
♪ What's up Gary Vee ♪
Let's get into the show.
(snaps fingers)
- [DRock] Um, okay,
you gonna do something?
- I am gonna do something.
You can keep that whole thing.
Maybe we'll black it out.
Let's do a little ode there to,
to Ask Gary, yeah.
- Ode to Gary Vee.
- I just want to give
a shout out to DRock.
Good to see you.
This is a very special episode
of Overrated/Underrated.
This is the sports card addition.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
One thing, with the
explosion of this show,
is I think I'm gonna use it
to answer the questions
that I get bombarded with
on text, 212-931-5731,
on DM, on social.
I see it all, but I'm busy.
I'm working all the time.
I'm doing my personal life stuff.
So, it's hard to answer them all.
I'm gonna use Overrated/Underrated
occasionally as a catchall.
This is the sports card edition.
- [DRock] PSA.
- PSA,
uh underrated.
It is the establishment.
As you know, DRock and others.
I love SGC.
I think there's a space for BGS.
I think there's some
other emerging players.
I do think longterm,
maybe there's a computer
that comes along
(computer beeps)
and takes the humans out of it.
But the group that just bought PSA
is some professional ass mother fuckers
and I expect big things from them.
And I'm a big fan, as you know,
on betting on the jockey over the horse.
If you go back to that Jack Welch post
maybe we'll pop that up right here,
that I posted on Instagram the other day
when we talked about Bezos,
- Jeff Bezos
- Big balls.
- Oh, my god.
(audience laughs)
Love 'em.
- Big hairy balls.
- Oh, god.
(audience laughs)
- In 2015, we just both loved them
'cause we were betting on the jockey.
It continued to play out.
I believe in the jockeys that now run PSA.
For everybody's watching this,
PSA is the grading company,
maybe we can throw an
image here and circle it,
that is like,
they grade cards on a 10 point scale.
This is like the most
respected grading company,
the leader in the space.
And so I think it's underrated
because I think there's new leadership
that will make it stronger.
And I'm excited to see what happens.
- [DRock] Alternative rookies.
- Alternative rookies
are grossly, grossly, grossly underrated.
Let's do some editing in this one.
I'm obsessed with the
Nike and Interlake Jordan.
I'm obsessed with the MSCI sticker.
I'm obsessed with,
Jesus, I'm tryin' to think of like,
there's a weird Stockton
rookie card from Europe,
that's a year before his rookie.
There's a Donut version
of a Pippen rookie card from '87, not '88.
There's the Barkley JMS from '85, not '86.
There's the Hank Aaron
rookie card, the Cookies.
There' these alternative rookie cards
that there's a Pat Riley Jack in The Box.
You know, these weird companies,
I view them as contemporary art.
I think what you're living
through now, with sports cards,
is the Pablo,
is kind of like the old
school European art,
the Jordans, the Mona Lisa shit.
The Jordans, the Mantles.
But I think as this industry explodes,
people are gonna look
at supply and demand.
And if you look at the supply
of these weird rookie cards,
there's so much less
than the established
Topps and Fleer version.
So, all it needs is demand.
(snaps fingers)
And as people get bored
and as people get creative
and as other dynamics happen,
as other people get excited about things,
this always happens in every sector.
I think Alternative rookie cards
are some of the biggest
money makers in cards
- [DRock] Stickers.
- Stickers, it's funny.
I just mentioned the MSCI thing.
I'm a big fan of the
sticker culture in Europe.
It's very simple,
stickers, Panini stickers,
and others but mainly Panini stickers,
European soccer cards are
actually stickers, right?
And so, to me,
as soccer,
proper football gets bigger in the U.S.,
the predominant in the market,
you see it with the Mbappe sticker, right?
You see with other stickers, Maradona, ZZ,
you know, you see it with other stickers,
they're exploding.
So, I think stickers in
general, interesting,
specifically for me, NBA stickers
because the Luka, Zion, all that stuff,
the stickers, pretty rare, hard to grade,
much tinier marketplace than the cards.
I think stickers in general
continue to get bigger
because,
and I'm not talking '86,
'87 Fleer Jordan stickers,
which were stickers and cards.
I mean actually stickers,
stand-alone stickers.
I like that whole space quite a bit
because I think European
proper football culture
continues to matter.
Those are stickers.
And so, I think stickers are sneaky.
Underrated.
- [DRock] Luka Base Prizm, PSA 10.
- Luka Base Prizm, PSA 10.
Um.
What's the population on that?
- [DRock] 26,214.
15,375 PSA 10s.
- One more time.
How many PSA 10s?
- [DRock] 15,000.
- 15,000.
What I'm asking for is the population.
How many are there perfectly graded
by the top company, PSA?
15,000.
So, I think about supply and demand.
This one's a very hard one for me.
Similar to just rating
Zion in the last episode,
the human, not the card.
I think Luka's so good
and will fall into that top 20
players of all time category,
If he doesn't get hurt.
Derek Rose, right?
That I'm scared to say overrated
but I'm scared about the population
because there's 15,000 plus of these.
There's still a ton of wax
to about 25,000, probably, in circulation.
That takes a lot of demand.
There's also a ton of other Luka cards,
including the super premiums
that we didn't have for
Barkley, Jakeem, Ewing,
other top 50 players,
where there's only the Fleer rookie.
In the next three years
it could be underrated.
But I'm gonna go with,
God.
I'm gonna go with properly rated
because even though long, longterm,
I think he could be overrated,
he just might end up being so good
that 25,000's not enough
against the,
supply against the demand
- [DRock] 2018 Panini Prizm Kylian Mbappe.
- The Mbappe Prizm rookie.
I think that's grossly overrated.
I think soccer, grossly overrated.
I think soccer stickers is the culture
and will be the culture.
And I think that's the rookie card.
The Mbappe first Prizm,
what's the population on that?
- [DRock] 2,309, PSA 10s.
- Yeah, I'm not as high on that.
A lot of people,
people are obsessed
with Prizm, in general.
I'm a little less obsessed with Prizm.
It's an incredible product.
I'm about it.
But I'm gonna go with overrated
even though I think Mbappe
is an incredible talent
as a soccer,
proper football player.
- [DRock] Marvel cards.
- Marvel cards are underrated.
I think comic book cards
is something I'm starting to try to,
by the way I wanna give how
many I have of these cards.
I think that'd be good transparency.
So, start one more time.
PSA, na.
- [DRock] You mean the Luka Base.
- Luka Base
(bells dings)
I think I have 183 of those.
(bell dings)
But if you remember,
throwback the throwback video,
(hip hop music)
This quarter was $35 when I
started buying it a year ago.
That Luka rookie is now 75.
I bought,
I was telling everybody on social media,
only 30 days ago to buy 'em.
They were 40.
- Wow.
- It is now over $400, tick-tock.
Sports cards are coming.
Get educated.
Get cash.
I bought almost all of
them for under $70 a piece.
As a matter of fact, I've never
paid over $70 for the Luka.
So, throw back a little video there.
So, I have about 185 of those.
What was the next card?
- [DRock] Kylian Mbappe.
(bells dings)
- Mbappe, I have none.
(buzzer sounds)
But I have like 10 or 15 of his stickers.
But you know, a lot of this is gonna be,
I'm buying the way I believe.
- [DRock] Marvel cards.
- Marvel cards, I have like,
I have like six random
weird things I bought,
which were like stickers from the '70s.
None of the modern '90, '91 stuff,
Upper Deck, da-da-da-da.
But I think it's underrated.
And I think I'm about to start
doing some real investigation
because I think,
you know, listen, like I've said,
that Charizard camp,
Tears ACL,
the Hulk, Batman, Superman,
there's some 1940 Superman
cards I'm starting to look at.
I think, in general, DC
and Marvel comic book cards
can have a moment.
(snaps fingers)
Underrated.
- [DRock] 2001 Upper Deck Tiger Woods.
- 2001 Upper Deck Tiger Woods,
I have a hundred BGS 9.5s.
(bell dings)
Just tryin' to give my transparency.
I think,
you know, you're catching me
right in between the week.
I'm sure we'll probably
post this next week,
which means the documentary on HBO's done
'cause the second part
comes up out this Sunday,
and we'll probably put
this out on Tuesday,
so it just ended.
I think there was like,
because of The Last Dance documentary,
everybody wants to buy
cards before documentaries.
Last Dance was a phenomenon.
I think super long-term,
that card,
what's the population on that?
- [DRock] 21,323.
And then 9,000 PSA 10s.
- And then there's,
Yeah.
I think it's overrated.
I'm gonna go with overrated.
I think, especially right now,
I think super long-term it can work out.
I do think the Sports Illustrated version
and the SP Authentic versions
are gonnabe the ones for Tiger.
It's Tiger.
If he gets weirdly hot again
and wins a couple more majors
but I'm going to go with overrated.
- [DRock] All right, Tyler
Herro Prizm rookie PSA,
- PSA 10?
- [DRock] PSA 10 is 28,
2,830.
- So, a couple of things.
I think Tyler Herro is super fun.
I think he's swaggy as shit.
I think he's a real good ballplayer.
I'm gonna go with aggressively,
aggressively, aggressively overrated.
And I'm gonna use this opportunity
to make a bigger point.
I think the biggest vulnerability
in sports cards right now
is rookie chasing,
for people that want to sit
on it a little bit longer
than within three and six
and nine and 12 week windows.
Ray Allen, Kevin Garnett,
Allen Iverson, Tracy McGrady.
I can go on and on.
Tim Duncan, who's a top
fuckin' 12 player of all time.
John Stockton, Reggie Miller.
If you look at the data around how much
how much is a Herro?
230 bucks or something like that?
- [DRock] Yeah, 235.
235.
- Right now
because people are day trading,
buying and flipping,
(snaps fingers)
buying and flipping
these young players,
Lamelo Ball's gonna go through stuff.
I think he's a baller.
It's gonna be this thing.
I also hate that year.
Is that,
that's last year, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Panini made a trillion of them.
It's the same reason, Moran and Zion.
I don't like the whole thing.
I don't like the rookie spec thing at all.
That's going on for this reason,
90% of the people that are
being bought right now,
this last four years,
somebody's gonna get held with the bag.
Like Jayson Tatum is a baller.
Is he gonna be one of 25
greatest players of all time?
Because if he's not,
then his rookie card,
in 12 years, is gonna be
a real fuckin' problem.
AKA, somebody's gonna
pay a lot more today,
then it's gonna be worth
a lot less than 12 years.
If he wins the championship next year,
and as the guy and you buy it today
and you sell it that night,
you're gonna make money.
Donovan Mitchell, Tatum,
Jaylen Brown,
there's so many great
young players, right?
Trae Young,
like they're loaded.
There's so much talent.
The problem is look at Barkley and Malone
and Ewing and Olajuwon
and Duncan and like Shaq.
Look at Shaquille fuckin' O'Neil,
culturally and actual player.
He was also a rookie during
high production years
and his cards are not,
Tyler, you're rookie cards
are more than Shaq fuckin' rookie cards,
in the same production.
And even,
I'm goin' of the top of my head,
I bet you'd be lookin' to pop
some certain Shaq, PSA 10s,
like the Topps regular
and the fuckin' Stadium
Club and the Upper Deck
versus Tyler Herro Prizms.
Tyler Herro's more expensive.
And there's still a ton
of Tyler Herro in wax.
Tyler Herro's not gonna end up
being a better all-time
player than Shaquille O'Neal.
I'm ready to put that down right now.
I think people are gonna get crushed
when the momentum goes the other way.
I think day trading day to day,
and you know what's going on sports,
you know who's hurt,
who's got an opportunity.
That's fun.
But I hate the long-term nature
of the majority of the rookie
speculating across the board.
Of course, there'll be four to five guys
that become Kobe's, LeBron's,
two or three guys that
become Kobe, LeBron, Shaq's.
Tim Duncan's,
you have to really hit it.
You got to really get
Mike Trout or LeBron,
otherwise, you know,
look how inexpensive Dwayne
Wade and Carmelo Anthony are.
Most of these,
almost 98% of these rookies
will not be better than Carmelo Anthony
all time on top 500 list.
(upbeat music)
- [DRock] 2003 Topps Chrome LeBron James
- Grossly underrated.
(bell dings)
I have 53 of them.
I didn't pay over 1100 for any of them.
They're 20,000 now.
It's gonna be $100,000 card one day.
LeBron James and Michael Jordan.
How many are there?
2,400 or something like that?
- [DRock] There are 21,000
147,
- Overall
- Overall.
- PSA 10s I mean.
- [DRock] 370.
- No, no, that's Jordan in '86.
I'm talking about LeBron.
- [DRock] I'm sorry, okay.
2,063.
Wow.
- I'm on my shit.
- Wow.
- 2000?
- [DRock] 83.
No, 63.
- Right, so, to me,
I know 2063 people
that are gonna want a LeBron
perfect, PSA 10 Chrome rookie
over the next decade.
People I've got 53 of them.
Other people got like,
That card's going to the moon.
- [DRock] Michael Jordan, PSA 10 1986.
(Gary laughs)
- I hate Michael Jordan more than anybody.
(bell dings)
I own two, I think.
I might have three.
(bells dings)
Which is the biggest mistake I've made
in the three years I've been in
because I've been yelling at,
you watch videos three years ago.
I fucked this up.
I beat 30K for mine.
There's 317 of them.
It's $230,000.
I'd be stunned.
If it's not a million dollars.
(snaps fingers)
The most underrated card.
It is the Mona Lisa, modern.
It is,
a big regret I have for not having more.
- [DRock] Golf cards.
- Golf cards are
underrated.
You know, cause that's how Tiger,
I don't even know what
a Phil Mickelson rookie
looks like in my eyes
or Johnson, Spieth or
whoever's like rockin' there.
So, I'm gonna go with slightly underrated.
I think all cards,
Garbage Pail Kids, Batman
the A-Team, golf.
You know, I think all of
it, right at this second,
underrated in a three-year window.
- [DRock] Wrestling Cards.
- Grossly underrated.
I think the Bumble Bee,
Dwayne, the Rock Johnson,
I think I own two of those, PSA 10,
which I think there's 30 of,
which is like now 14,000.
I think it's massively under-priced.
Talk about a six-figure card.
These guys are uncultured.
They're also,
Hulk Hogan and Andre Giant
are much more of the Hulk and Batman
than they are Hank Aaron
and Roberto Clemente.
I think wrestling cards,
great community in wrestling.
If wrestling has like 16 to 25 people
in the wrestling community
get hardcore about cards,
that's a big ecosystem of diehards
that I think come in hard.
I think wrestling is
actually very under-priced.
- [DRock] 2019 Panini
Prizm Zion Williamson.
- Grossly, grossly overpriced.
What's the production?
Overrated.
- [DRock] 26,926.
14,673 PSA 10s.
- Massively.
I'm more confident Luka's
a top 15 player than Zion,
at this second.
It's just too much inventory.
These guys have to go on to become
one of the 15 best players of all time
to make these numbers work.
I think the Zion's like seven, 800 bucks.
It's been 1,000.
I don't see it.
Garnett.
Is Zion gonna be better
than Garnett all time?
I think so
but I'm not confident.
I just think there's way too much risk.
There's so many places to
spend $700 better today.
So many places.
You know, we've talked about,
I think one of the underrated places
is that '90s era
that, you know,
Garnett, Ray Allen, Iverson, Mano Genova.
There's some cheap, good deals there
compared to these youngsters,
who I love.
Great kids but fuck.
- [DRock] 2003 Mega
Craques Cristiano Ronaldo.
- There's so few of these
Ronaldo and MSCI cards.
Let's do a lot of imaging,
post image so everybody can see this.
How much is it?
Do you know?
- [DRock] I don't know.
- There's so few, right?
- [DRock] We don't know the population.
There's 38 PSA 10s.
- Yeah, I mean, under,
underrated.
It's one of the 10 best proper
football players of all time.
He's culturally relevant.
Soccer cards are gonna continue to go up.
It's a good chunk below MSCI, if I recall.
I haven't looked recently
but I'm gonna go under-priced.
- [DRock] 2013 Topps
Bloodline Conor McGregor Auto.
- Under-priced.
I think UFC cards are under-priced.
I bought two of those UFC Connors recently
and I think UFC cards are under-priced.
UFC, MMA is a huge sport for a long time.
I think people haven't gotten there yet.
I think UFC is a place to go.
- [DRock] There's only 36.
Population 27.
- It's a really interesting card.
- [DRock] 2018 Topps Update Juan Soto.
- I think properly priced.
I think there's a ton of
inventory there as well.
I think it's cheap though,
compared to the basketball stuff.
And I think Soto could be the best player.
He can be one of the 17
best players of all time.
He's young, Derek Rose again.
But I'm gonna go with under-priced.
I like that card a lot.
I liked Soto a lot.
I have 25 of those,
(bell dings)
I think at this point.
Maybe more.
Maybe 75.
(bell dings)
- [DRock] Luka's mother's autograph.
(Gary laughs)
- I think that's an underrated story.
This is like a rumor that goes around
that Lucas moms signed
this cards his rookie year,
not him.
I don't,
I really haven't done,
I don't get excited about
conspiracy theories.
So, I don't have really a lot of info
but it's an underrated story.
- [DRock] Kaboom inserts.
- Kaboom inserts are underrated.
This has been the biggest thing
that my brother, AJ, has invested in.
I think 85% of AJ's behavior is Kaboom.
I've got probably a mix
of like 35, 40 Kabooms.
Mainly basketball, 2013.
I do have a bunch of Sam Darnold Kabooms,
so I've got a lot riding on Sammy,
but probably only like 40 or 50 overall.
Kaboom is an insert.
It's extremely rare.
They've got the comic book element.
They've got the supply and demand element.
They got the heat on the street.
Kaboom's like,
you know what Kaboom is?
I could see like Michael
B. Jordan, the actor,
being like I'm gonna get into this.
Be like, oh, these
Kabooms are fresh, right?
I can see the baby being
like, all right Gary Vee
and I'll be like, here's
what you should buy, Jordan.
He'll be like, fuck it.
I'm gonna get these Kabooms.
They're fuckin' fresh.
They're like, they're icy.
They're the one.
The Kaboom insert to me is the one.
I think they're grossly under-priced.
I think with the comic book and the,
and how rare they are,
as people get educated about Kaboom,
I think that's the one.
- [DRock] 2017 Prizm Patrick Mahomes.
- I own none of those
(buzzer sounds)
regrettably.
What's the population of the PSA 10?
- [DRock] 849.
- Yeah, it's under,
I think it's under-priced.
I think Patrick Holmes, barring injury,
becomes one of the best quarterbacks,
if not top three quarterbacks of all time.
I'm pretty sad.
I don't have any of those.
- 1979 O-Pee-Chee
Wayne Gretzky.
- O-Pee-Chee.
Grossly under-priced.
I mean, are we seeing the PSA 10?
Yeah, I mean, aren't there
three of them or two.
Yeah, I mean,
somebody just paid over a million for it.
If, in 10 years, if
that's a $10 million card,
that would make sense to me.
(snaps fingers)
I think it's grossly under-priced.
He's the greatest hockey
player of all time.
Super rare.
There's only two in the world.
You get into the Mona
Lisa shit, under-priced
- [DRock] Card funds
- Card funds are underrated.
I don't think people realize
how many people are circling around
raising five, 10, $15 million
that are gonna lead to
$10 million Wayne Gretzky,
gonna lead to Kaboom's being 10X,
Gonna lead to Jordan being a million.
I think card funds,
real capital, Wall Street life.
You know, I'm not involved in any.
I don't know any real detail
but I know I get emailed all the time.
I am Stanley Thompson from Merrill Lynch.
We are putting together a $10 million fund
to buy sports cards.
Would you like,
and I'm trying to stay very omni.
That's I'm trying to be
pretty transparent with my,
what my holdings are, my opinions here.
But if you look at all my videos
I think I've been ridiculously
historically correct.
And I feel like card funds are underrated.
I don't think people
understand the financial impact
of $400 million coming into the market
trying to get the top 10% of stuff.
- [DRock] The bubble.
The bubble is underrated, in the reverse.
This is why everything
is in detail, right?
I think,
I think at any moment,
you know, Pokemon can come out.
Video games can come out.
Things change.
Something might capture the
attention of all these people.
Comic books, graded video games.
You know, you gotta always
pay attention to that.
You should always be
worried you're in a bubble,
which means you don't mortgage the house.
You're smart.
(bell dings)
You're thoughtful.
(bells dings)
You do things that you like,
(bell dings)
things you can afford.
Every card I own, I make
pretend I go to zero.
(bell dings)
And I think people have to do that.
Don't underestimate the bubble
(snaps fingers)
'cause that will pop on your face.
- [DRock] 1961 Fleer Oscar Robertson.
(Gary laughs)
- Did John Morganson have
anything to do with this list?
- [DRock] Yeah, he helped
with all the Topps.
(Gary laughs)
- I love it.
I own probably about nine or 10 of these.
Maybe 12.
Under 20, for sure.
Listen, I think vintage is,
'61 FLeer basketball,
'70 Topps basketball,
'72 Topps basketball,
the Jordan, Magic, Byrd.
I think vintage basketball's
wildly under-priced.
I've been a three-year
a broken record on this.
So, I'm gonna go, in general,
Are we saying which PSA
or is it just that card?
- [DRock] There's 1 PSA 10.
- Yeah, I mean, that's stupid.
- [DRock] And there's 1,100 total.
- Yeah, it's,
I think the top 20,
the top 50 players in the NBA, in history,
are collectively under-priced.
And Oscar '61 is one of those cards.
You know, the '48 Mike and,
those cards are just
gonna keep slow, da-doot.
Everyone's like, oh my Dr. J
hasn't gotten as much as this thing.
I'm like, sure.
But like,
- [DRock] 2003 Topps Chrome Dwayne Wade.
- How many are the PSA 10s are there?
- [DRock] 654.
- Do you know how much it is right now?
- [DRock] No.
- Cool.
I think Dwayne Wade's under-priced
because of what I think
he's up to post-career.
I think he's a top 100 player
and I think he's culturally relevant.
If Dwayne Wade ended up being
President of the United States of America,
that would not surprise me,
based on his humanity, his
amazingness as a human,
oh, by the way, I own probably
four or five of these,
his culture.
He's just a leader.
Him and his wife, his family,
I just,
I think he's under-priced,
so I'm gonna go with underrated.
- [DRock] Ebay.
- Underrated.
It's the fuckin' most important platform.
In stock, actually doing a nice job.
People are selling direct, discords.
But Ebay is the fuckin' industry.
It's it's the data.
- [DRock] Sports card values in 2026.
- Sports card value in 2026.
Underrated in the super premium, low pop,
vintage, or three, four best players,
the Trouts and the LeBrons
of their generation.
(mumbles)
Overrated on a lot of this thing
that I'm trying to explain to people.
There's a lot of speculating goin' on.
Some kid can have one good night
and people are like, buy.
I think people are gonna get burned.
This is exactly what happened in '92, '94.
Get thoughtful,
unless you're day trading,
then it's different.
Buy, kid gets gets hot for a week.
Devonte Graham.
You can make money.
I get it.
That's the show.
Hope you learned something.
See ya.
There's 2,830 Tyler Herro PSA 10s.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- There's an unbelievable amount of packs
still in the world,
so we're probably another four X.
So it'll get to 10,000.
But let's even say it's
at this number, 2,800.
There's 1,944 Shaquille O'Neal's.
Right?
So there's,
right?
So, right.
So, there's a good chunk,
2800, you said there?
- [DRock] Yeah, 2830.
- Right.
So, there's like a 25% less Shaq's
and Shaq is $380
and Tyler Herro is 230.
- [DRock] Mm-hm.
- And when you take in the Vig,
that makes no sense.
- [DRock] Mm-hm.
- That's the problem.
There's 315 Shaq Upper Deck,
excuse me, Stadium,
Upper Deck bases.
And there's only 315 of them
and it's to 2600 bucks.
Like,
Shaq is either stupid,
stupid, stupid under-priced
or Tyler Herro, Luka, Trout,
like all these guys are
just wildly overpriced.
John, Jeren, Jackson,
that's the problem.
Supply and demand.
YouTube watcher, what's up.
It's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.